avanzan las labores de salvamento que
Naciones Unidas emprendió en el
petrolero fafer
las autoridades recalcaron que la
contratación de un seguro para operación
es un paso fundamental para continuar la
tarea
estamos en una carrera contrarreloj Así
que insto a los dirigentes de los
gobiernos a los directores generales de
las empresas y a cualquier persona que
esté en condiciones de contribuir que
den un paso al frente y nos apoyen para
que continúe esta operación que está
alcanzando rápidamente una fase crítica
esta embarcación contiene 1,14 millones
de barriles de crudo y el deterioro de
su estructura por la falta de
mantenimiento ausentes desde el
estallido del conflicto en 2015 la han
transformado en una grave amenaza
ambiental y hay alertas de que podría
quebrarse o explotar En caso de que eso
sucediera el seifer amarrado en las
costas de shemen desde 1988 podría
vertir cuatro veces más de petróleo en
el mar rojo que el desastre del exson
Valdés de 1989 en Alaska considerado de
los más graves en el rubro además pone a
200.000 medios de vida en peligro 17
millones de personas se verían afectadas
por las consecuencias y costaría
aproximadamente 20 mil millones de
dólares limpiar el